Jeff is with us to start off this hour
in Dallas Texas
I Jeff how are you fine Dave how are you
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I have a question on
budgets recently read your Total Money
Makeover at a sister soon to me many
years ago and finally picked up and read
through it so we ended up getting baby
stuff step one done and my question is
when I do my budget I'm still going in
the red which is driving me nuts
mm-hmm now I did talk to my wife and
she's on board with what you say because
I've felt instead of listening to you
before and I guess things are just
sinking in you know I'm at the age that
close to retirement but there's nothing
there because of life happens so want to
be out of debt and that's my goal is the
tail what is your household income right
now it's about a hundred thousand okay
and um how much debt do you have not
counting your home I probably have about
ten or fifteen thousand part of that is
from the Health Care Act that I got
screwed over off so you don't home money
are penalized yeah I don't I don't have
a credit cards you don't I don't have
any in the car payments car notes right
okay so I'm a little confused how a
hundred grand with no debt virtually is
causing but I rather doubt what was
wrong well you did a budget where did
the money go
I I see it as it goes to who you know
groceries I pay the rent I do this I do
that but I don't see where it's going
but maybe a it's the budget baby so what
is your take home page should be what
$6,500 a month right yeah well it's
probably close to about four or five a
month no it's Nora file
no it's not well I mean $100,000 and 300
a month you do not have $4,000 coming
out of your check okay something's
screwy yeah either your income figures
wrong or are you taking out a 401 K yes
I restarted funding my 401 K which is
$100 a week so that's 400 a month that's
$5,000 a year that's not a right here
are you paying a bunch of costs out of
something out of your check
no well I I recently looking at redoing
my health care so my health care was at
700 and I caught on your show yesterday
and I got a guy from that chair to see
about what we can do on that okay but
I'm just not seeing where the money is
and I guess it's just frustrated because
number one we need to figure out where
some of your money are you getting a
huge tax refund no I've had to pay for
the last three or four years with you
know let me just stop a second and just
do the math with nine here okay
$100,000 a years eight thousand three
hundred and thirty three dollars a month
you talk about gross gross okay okay
your taxes should be somewhere around
1,500 maybe $2,000 you should be taking
home around six thousand five hundred
dollars something like that and then if
you take out and then if you take out
you know $700 for health care and a
hundred two hundred dollars a month or
said four hundred oh you said 100 a week
so $400 a month $1100 for your health
care and your 401 K we're still not down
in the four thousands so something's off
at least a thousand maybe 1500 bucks
with that figure you got to go find that
to start with or you just told me your
income wrong
well I'm basing it from what I made last
year yeah
no and that's all that always salary
every month do what is that salary every
month no I'm not salary I'm hourly okay
all right well just kind of back into
that and you know what you need to do is
go discover that that's the first thing
you need to do and then let's put $5,000
at the top of the page and your rent is
how much we recently got it redone and
now it's 6:37 okay
so 5,000 - 600 right mm-hmm I'm down to
four thousand four hundred four thousand
three hundred okay right and you're you
know food I mean to people
seven hundred bucks at 700 bucks right
I'm down to three thousand and you got
to pay lights and water right this is
doing a battery you and I are doing a
budget right now this is your income -
every dollar has an assignment down the
page III I'm missing thousands of
dollars yeah and that's where I am - and
I've searched online for you know
different one that you have I did found
a budget that somebody is from you they
can't they did it it's an EOD test and I
have a budget that I've we've done but
it's just crazy I can't figure out where
all this money is going okay well I mean
you need to find it because it's going
somewhere when you do a budget you
should not be in the red on paper with
the numbers you're giving me this is
dramatically screwed up and so you know
you need to start with your income at
the top of the page and find out where
every dollar is going and or tell every
dollar where it should go maybe try the
every dollar budget online maybe the app
will help you you may want to get in
touch with one of our coaches and sit
down with them and walk you through it
the budget forms are in the back of the
book you've got the Total Money Makeover
book the every dollar budget app for
your iPhone or your Android is free you
can jump on and use it try that but
basically the concept is pretty simple
and you know you need to find where this
money is going something is two to three
thousand dollars off in the numbers that
you and I discussed every month which is
like substantial okay your take-home pay
is wrong something screwed up about that
and then once you do get it home you you
know you after you take out rent and
food and lights and water you don't have
a lot of other necessity expenses and
you can you need to write down before
the month begins where this money is
going to go and tell it where to go and
don't do anything with it other than
that and when you do that your budget is
you telling your money what to do before
the month begins and once you put it on
paper you're the boss of the budget
until you get the budget done then the
boat then the budgets the boss of you
it's you telling you how this household
is gonna run how we're gonna live this
is what we're gonna do because the way
we've been doing it for this last 60
years hasn't been working and it's time
to change some stuff so every dollar has
an assignment very very important and
then stick to that this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]